hi everyone welcome on Zoom this time
welcome to cs330
um today we'll be talking about lifelong
learning which is a a very interesting
area of research which is not very well
defined and we'll talk about it and
you'll kind of get to experience why
that is
um a few things regarding Zoom lettering
if you have any questions please raise
your hand on Zoom you can also write a
question in chat
um I won't be monitoring all of this at
all times but we have our lecture
coordinator
with us who will then speak up anytime
there is a raised hand or a question to
us that the World Trade to answer these
um all right so a few reminders
um so this is
um so this Wednesday will be our
um last lecture and both the lecture as
well as the instructor office hours will
be over soon
um so it will be in a similar setting
like we have today
um one thing that I would like to tell
you is that um we'll have we'll talk
about Frontiers and open problems in
multitask and meta learning and we'll
have
um maybe six to eight researchers who
work on Frontiers will tell us briefly
about some of the recent papers some of
the recent projects and you you will
you'll have a chance to meet them and
ask them questions because it's all in
Zoom so it's a little bit easier
um to do it for them
um so I would encourage you to
participate and kind of get to know the
people behind the research as well as
the research that is happening
um in addition the the two remaining
reminders are that on Tuesday we'll have
the project poster session and then on
Wednesday review
right so the plan for today is the
following we'll talk about the lifelong
learning problem statement
um then we'll talk about some basic
approaches to Lifeline learning how we
can how we can address that problem
then we can talk we'll talk about how we
can do better than these basic
approaches
um also using some of the insights that
we learned from the class already
and then we'll revisit the problem
statement from the mental learning
perspective
all right so
um let's do a brief overview of the
problem statements that we discussed so
far
so we talked about multi-desk learning
are we trying to learn to solve a set of
tasks and in that case we had some kind
of path that we
um that we had to learn that were that
were given to us upfront and then we
were evaluated based on the exact same
tasks so we are not really testing the
generalizations to unseen tasks but we
train on the set of tests and then we
evaluate on the exact same set of tasks
and then we also talked about meta
learning where given an ID task
distribution we try to learn a new task
efficiently so we'll learn to learn
different tasks in that case you were
given a set of tasks of training time
and then at test time you'll be tested
or you will be it will be measured how
quickly you can learn a new tasks that
you haven't seen before
right so in that case we are learning we
are testing how quickly we can adapt to
a new task you've never seen
however in both of these in both of
these cases
um
the we we assume that the tasks that you
can practice on or that you can learn at
the beginning are kind of given to you
up front you kind of have them at your
disposal right off the bat and you can
you know sample them differently you
have access to all of them at all times
but um in contrast many real world
settings look a little bit different
in contrast the way it looks is usually
that you're given a task that you have
to perform and then after you perform
the task for a little bit you're given a
new task
right and you don't really have access
to the old task you now you have to
focus on the new task that you just got
and then you do this over time and every
every now and then you're given a new
task if you haven't seen before and you
have to kind of you're measured how well
you're doing on that task and you don't
have all of the tasks up front available
to you
so basically our agents may not be given
a large batch of data or tasks right off
the bat instead they're a revealing key
they're being revealed to you slowly
over time
a few examples when when this happens
for instance with student learning
Concepts in school right like you go
from one class to another you go to
algebra one and then after algebra one
you pass your tests or your exams then
you go to Algebra 2 and then based on
the content in Algebra 2 you're being
evaluated how well you're doing in
algebraic
and so on and so forth
you're not really given all the material
all up front and you're not being tested
on all of the different classes these
are being revealed to you progressively
another example would be a deployed
image specification
system that is learning from a stream of
of images from users
um so in that case it's an image
classification system and since maybe
the
um the things that users want over the
change over time and because of that
um this image classification system will
be seeing very different images over
time
right we will also be getting new users
new users might maybe shift the data
distribution a little bit so we won't
have access to all the kind of things
that the users might want at the
beginning
another example could be a robot who's
that is acquiring an increasingly large
set of skills in many different
environments
um so in that case you know you might
have a robot that you deploy in a
certain setting for instance you wanted
to clean your kitchen and then it learns
how to clean the kitchen and it gets
better and then you can use it for
cleaning the kitchen but then you want
the robot to move to a different room
and now do something else in that group
right maybe you wanted to do laundry now
so in that case this new task is being
revealed only once you move the robot to
the into the laundry room and then the
robot is being evaluated on this new
task that was given to it at the current
time as opposed to having all the tasks
available up front
another example would be a virtual
assistant that is learning to help users
or different users with different tasks
at different points in time
um so the virtual assistant our
preferences when we talk to it might
change over time we will also it also
might need to adjust to different users
um to constantly changing preferences to
maybe we want them we want the virtual
assistant to do different tasks and so
on so in that case it's also being
revealed to new and new everything on
them
and then lastly
um another example could be a doctor's
assistant aiding in medical decision
making where not only the users might be
changing their preferences and so on but
also new diseases might be common uh for
instance you know a few years ago a
doctor's assistant didn't have to help
with things like um sort of thing like
covid-19 now it's uh should be able to
handle that so thereby being new
diseases there might be new treatments
and so on and it should be able to
adjust to these
right so these are some some examples
now let's talk about some terminology
so
um the terminology is actually
um not very well defined in this field
so we'll talk a little bit about this
um so we usually refer to this as
sequential learning setting and it you
can see it under many different names so
some people call it online learning some
people call it lifelong learning
continual learning incremental learning
uh streaming data and I think there's
probably a few more
um the important part is that this is
this thing from sequence data so for
instance text where
um you know the the words come in
sequence that doesn't necessarily mean
that this is a sequential learning
setting where you're being or you see
the tasks uh that are being revealed to
you over time and it's also different
from sequential decision making that we
discussed in the case of reinforcement
learning where you might need to reason
about the actions and how they're going
to influence the future but you can
still have all the data available to you
up front and the data might not be
changing over
as it is for instance the casing with uh
with offline reinforcement learning
yeah so one of the lifelong learning
problem statement
so actually to kind of show you what it
is and um to maybe get you a little bit
more engaged we'll do a little exercise
so the exercises to follow
um we'll split you into breakout rooms
we'll do it in a second and in each
record room you'll pick an example
setting
the example setting could be one of the
examples having because I just discussed
these five examples that I gave her you
can think of your own example setting
and then you'll discuss a problem
statement in your breakout room and
there are a few questions I want to ask
you so first
um please think about how you would set
up an experiment to develop and test
your algorithm
right so kind of it's a question about
how you would be if you were to create a
lifelong learning algorithm how would
you go about this and how would you
actually implement it in terms of an
experiment and then how would you test
that it works
secondly
um think about what are the desirable or
required properties uh for lifelong
learning algorithm right so what are the
things that you would want to test and
what kind of what kind of things you
would want to focus on when you develop
a lifelong learning algorithm
and then third
um it's kind of similar to what we're
already asking a how would you evaluate
such a system right so exactly what kind
of numbers you would be plotting
um so that you you know that uh that
it's getting better or it uh it has the
desirable required properties at least
that
um all right so the example settings
that I gave before are here a few
Logistics so we'll split you into
breakout rooms
um I think I'm not sure how many people
we have on a call but I think we will uh
we'll decide in a second how many people
have been in each record room and then
um let's say that if you're
um the first letter of your first name
is closer to the beginning of the
alphabet you will be the person
responsible for presenting the the
results will give you all five minutes
to discuss these questions and then
um we'll ask you about your findings and
I'll take some notes
um anything else if there's someone else
who in your record room who would rather
present it that's also totally fine just
uh either if you can't really decide
let's pick the person uh it was first
letter of the first name is sponsored to
the beginning of the alphabet
um all right so let's Splatoon the
breakout rooms
and I'll see you in five minutes
after I should be back now all right
great cool I hope you had good
conversations about the problem
statement
so let me switch to the slides Okay cool
so I want to ask
um groups one by one to tell me about
desirable properties and considerations
and then also about the evaluation set
up separately and I will try to take
some notes so let's start with room
number one
yeah I can talk about it
okay cool cool uh so yeah the example
setting details was uh League of Legends
or any other game for that matter
um
and yeah so the exciting would be we
have a game box that's learning how to
play the game
um yeah the reason why this should be
considered lateral learning is because
there are constant batches that are
released like once every month or so and
the bot has to adapt like like adaptive
player around that like pick the right
Champions pick the right game strategies
stuff like that so uh for the experiment
to development that's targeting uh it
would just be like the experiment would
just be like gameplay and then we could
like accumulate data over batches for
like four games and then
um yeah it would have to like we would
see like the way we tested is whether or
not we'd like to learn to adapt uh after
every part is released and it learns to
play what The Meta picks are uh as in
like what the best strategies to play
and then
um yeah pretty much we just had to see
whether another bot changes in strategy
as as you know game environment changes
or being a patches
okay I think okay and um so what would
be so you'd be just measuring the the
Pure Performance after the Patch is that
right yeah that's correct uh there's
like a reading of how you play at the
end of the game so that reading would be
the sort of the way we measure
performance okay cool
um I think that makes sense so it should
adapt
um
well it's difficult to write unless I
shouldn't have just getting after
the patch
um
and then could you tell me so
um would you give it like a certain
window where it can it can adapt to the
new patch when it can kind of
um see you know what the New Path check
so yes or would you measure the
performance straight away
yeah so if it meets it up quickly enough
to keep up with the rest of the players
the players that like human players
themselves take like about a week
sometimes like that and there's like a
patch like approximately ones that we
want or like one to one and a half
months uh so it would have to adapt
maybe at least even adapts lower than
the human players then it's ranking the
players like the boss ranking would go
down in the system but like if it could
adapt faster or like even at the same
time so
like the speed of adaptation is really a
critical Factor here for sure okay but
you would assume that within a week it
should be able to adapt and there is a
new patch coming out every month is that
right correct okay cool
and will you ever evaluate it on the alt
performance so let's say a new patch
came out but you also make sure that
before the patch you know with the
previous version does it still work
uh not really it's like the game changes
too but I think we I feel like the
intellically sounds change and the way
people like it's like a completely
different game almost after every patch
I don't know like in a way it's like
there are common factors and the main
goal of the game is just saying You
Gotta Go destroy the towers like be
other Champions take the Nexus but like
the way you play the game like the
strategies
[Music]
it's like it's like a whole different
game which is kind of what makes people
addicted to it because it's like it
keeps standing constantly over time so
it's like people keep like playing a new
game every time it makes people want to
come back
cool awesome
um yeah this is a great example is there
anything else that you would like to add
I think it's pretty much good all right
thank you
um let's move to the group number two to
room number two
and uh can you hear me yes
we talked about how we would set up the
experiment by just uh doing sort of an
ablation test on having all the tests at
once versus uh doing the test on a
random warning and uh similar to
homework for how we have multiple
episodes within a single trial uh we
would have multiple episodes let's just
say like five episodes uh in a random
order and each episode has a different
cast we asked to say
um and then
we would uh test the cumulative return
on all of the episodes so I guess in
this example five different tasks and
that's how we would evaluate our
algorithm
so it will be some of returns across all
the episodes
yeah
okay
and you would be comparing you'll be
comparing it to having all the tasks
available to you up front
right okay cool so what are the
desirable properties
we talked about how there might be a
distribution shape in the tasks that you
see earlier in training versus later on
in training so it should be adaptable to
that distribution shift and it should be
able to either remember or forget
uh certain skills that it learns based
on kind of like an lstm I guess if it
like deems that are necessary for future
tasks that should forget
right and then we also talked about the
capacity of the model should be uh they
should have a large capacity because at
the end of training you would
in theory uh be able to do all of the
skills that you saw in the past
oh interesting
um
so sorry I didn't get that so you're
saying that the capability should be
um or the capacity of the model should
be really big or it should be or it
should be big enough to be able to solve
all of the tasks yes
very much
okay big enough
capacity
okay and then
um in terms of a concrete task you would
evaluated on you would take something
like the task from homework for
uh yeah we were going with the robot
example because we were talking about
sort of a reinforcement learning context
okay cool awesome thank you anything
else that you would like to add
all right thanks a lot and let's move to
group number three
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
so what we're thinking
um in terms of like uh in terms of like
evaluating
um an algorithm for this is like maybe
keeping track open like over time
keeping some sort of like um test set of
images across a series of times
um and essentially as we add more images
we have sort of like
um filter or like display off some to
actually test that a while also perhaps
like dropping off some of the older
images with some uh like Paul dolphin
[Music]
uh more
what who will be controlling how it
changes
uh so
like what we're thinking is like over
somebody buys stores perhaps newer faces
than this classifications as long as
like maybe like faces that showed up
earlier in the
um like earlier industry of images may
not be as relevant now or I may not uh
uh application
um in addition to our communities
perhaps being on average higher quality
yeah
I see that makes sense and then the
desirable property is that
um the algorithm does well on newer
images yeah
[Music]
better I guess on uh on images that are
essentially more common nowadays so for
example if like some uh individual
person that's like super relevant to
facial Constitution nowadays like uh uh
I don't know
um uh we want to be very actually
expensive
um classifying who
um who uh who Professor Finn is then
maybe want to essentially buy us perhaps
our test set towards uh towards those
things
these types of images
so like biased towards
um
more important images whatever that
means
okay I think that that sounds good
um
and uh will you be still evaluating on
all the images or all you know people
are also changing and their faces are
changing will you always keep a certain
set of images from the past to make sure
that it does well on those
yeah I think we um
like I guess it depends on a little bit
on like the downstream application
because I'm thinking in most cases uh we
may want to like keep some old answers
but also like slowly like decrease their
proportion so like uh something I messed
up getting was like maybe
um essentially have like a drop off
probability uh as we move on like we
have uh some chance of like gradually uh
copying each of the older images
on the newer ones
yeah okay I think that makes sense cool
um is there anything else that you'd
like to add
no not me
[Music]
thank you
um
and thank you back to the lecture but
also there's okay
um the Wednesday lecture will be also on
Zoom so you know
all right room number four I think
that's our last room
well I guess I can talk about it
um so uh we continue to sort of General
classification setting where each task
is a classification problem
um so maybe a bit similar to the first
situation where you have a student
playing any concepts and um the students
sort of asked questions what are the
discrete some answers
um in addition to what you mentioned
previously
um we thought that
um we considered two additional
evaluation metrics so uh one of them is
sort of a forward transfer so um ideally
if we train in one task
um that would improve performance for
future tasks as well
in the future we'd like to retain
knowledge or maybe even improve
knowledge for tasks that we've seen
previously
okay yeah that's uh that's a really good
point so prevent catastrophic forgetting
and to do this you would keep I guess a
set of images or a set of
evaluations for all their tasks
after three minutes
okay okay and how would you evaluate
forward transfer so you will be given a
new a new set of images so assume or a
new set of tasks and then will you have
some kind of burning period where you
can adapt or will you be evaluating this
straight away
okay okay
cool
um
um is there anything else that you would
like to add
[Music]
that's how we discussed earlier
um
I'm not sure if I put the notes in the
right column sometimes but uh I tried to
put them there and put them whatever
you're saying
um awesome thank you so much and to all
four groups
um so one thing we can now experience
that um first the um examples were um
quite diverse I guess we have two image
classification settings but um overall
we have robotic selling we have League
of Legends setting human specification
um so that's that's really great to see
and in terms of how to evaluate things
um you can see that it actually changes
quite a bit some algorithms look at
backward compatibilities from don't
um like group number four cared about
preventing catastrophic forgetting group
number one that didn't really care about
this because you only need to adjust to
the newest patch and group number three
had something in between
um
then we see that different different
groups would evaluate the algorithm
overall differently group number two
would compare it to the performance that
we see when we train on all of the tasks
versus with some other groups we'll look
at um how well and how well our learning
transfers to the next task and things
are great cool
um
yeah so there's quite a lot of
variability so here are a few problem
variations that I thought of as well
um so one variation that we can have is
whether
um we know about the task and data order
and whether it's predictable or whether
it's just ID
um or whether it's some kind of
curriculum or if it's adversarial to us
and so on so if it's ID then it's just
we're given new tasks every now and then
and um
and that's it they come from the same
distribution if it's predictable then
maybe it's something like um the seasons
where you can predict that there are
certain
um you know there's a very period
acidity to them so like you know summer
comes every year and so on
um they can come in the form of a
curriculum where you get harder and
harder tasks like you do in in school
for instance or they could be
adversarial maybe that's the case in
League of Legends or maybe the new
patches or so that the all strategies
are not really working with the new
patch
uh the other consideration of sweater we
have discrete task boundaries versus
continuous shift so sometimes you you
can clearly tell that the test is
Blended A New Path has been released and
from now on you know the game is
different there's a very discrete task
boundary versus if it's for instance a
weather that is changing it may be
harder to say you know at this point the
weather has changed the weather is kind
of continuously shifting
and we could also have instance of
instances
then we can have known task boundaries
so you know someone can tell us that
they released a new patch or unknown
uh that we don't need to detect in some
way
and in terms of some considerations
um a lot of them you talked about as
well so model performance we can also
look at data efficiency how much data we
need to achieve a certain performance
these are kind of similar metrics that
we would use in standard supervised
learning settings
we can also look at computational
resources
and the memory so whether we need to
keep all the old test data all the all
tasks in the memory or not it was the
memory footprint of the algorithm
and then there are other things such as
privacy interpretability fairness test
time compute and memory so um these are
things that are really important and
they're also important in supervised
learning settings that are
um that are also applied here
um but one thing to note that I would
like you to keep in mind is that there's
actually substantial Variety in the
problem statement itself
and when we discussed some other types
of learning before like multi-task
learning meta learning reinforcement
learning multitasker enforcement
learning and so on
um the problem statement is relatively
rigid like it's it's well it's well
defined we know what we are optimizing
for and if you look at you know
different papers doing offline
reinforced learning very often they
would assume they would have exact same
assumptions and they would be trying to
solve the same problem them this is
often not the case in the lifelong
learning setting and this is something
to keep in mind when you read lifelong
learning
um papers
all right
so
um let's go over the general definition
of how a general supervised online
learning problem looks like and how
people usually think about it and then
we'll also talk about how what are the
different ways to evaluate it that are
kind of well as published and some of
them you already mentioned
um so for the general online supervised
learning problem for every task or for
every data point it will observe our X
then we'll have to predict the Y
and then we'll get to observe the link
right so you kind of you get the X and
you have to predict the output and then
you get to observe the label only after
that
um if this could happen in the IID
setting where um the access the the
probability of P of X as well as P of Y
given X is not time dependent this is a
uh this probability distribution doesn't
change over time
um or it could be a time dependent
distribution where we have where our XT
is coming from the distribution p t of X
and the same for y t is coming from
distribution PD of Y given X so the
distribution is changing over time and
we talk about different ways how it
would be changing it could be a
curriculum it could be adversarial and
so on
then um we sometimes also consider a
training setting in which you can't
really store your current pairs of XT
and YT so you kind of have to make a
prediction but you can't really store
those
and there's various reasons for that for
instance you don't have the memory to do
that for instance you're trying to do
some work on video and video streaming
at very high frequency and you don't
really have enough memory to store all
the different images that you see in the
video
sometimes you don't have enough
computational resources to do that
there could be some privacy
considerations where you can't really
store images of people for instance
or when you want to study neural memory
mechanisms there are some that are
biologically uh plausible mechanisms how
we memorize things and how we adapt and
in that case you know we don't really
have a a very hard hard memory like we
do in computers where we can just store
all the data
um so when people study these kind of
mechanisms they usually also assume the
streaming setting
so overall there's a story in some cases
but also not in many other cases and
most of the cases we'll be discussing
today will be the cases where
um it don't really have to be in the
streaming setting you you are allowed or
you can store uh the data as you see it
um and we actually already discussed
some of these things for instance in the
case of Replay buffers or I mean
reinforcement learning you can be
storing your experiences you can keep
storing everything you see in the replay
buffer and then you have algorithms that
can retrieve that experience from The
Reflex buffer and learn based on that
foreign
then one other note regarding the the
online learning problem if we have um
observable task batteries if we know
that a new task is coming then we would
not only observe the new data point XT
but we'll also know what task it comes
from so at some depicted by some task
descriptor ZTE for instance a one hot
vector or natural language description
or something like that
all right
so then the next question is how do we
evaluate it what what do we actually
want from a Lifeline learning algorithm
and what people usually refer to here
are two measures and uh the first one is
Regret
um so what people usually want is
minimal regrets or regret that grows
slowly with number of paths or with
number of data points and regret is
actually a well-defined mathematical
quantity
and it's defined as following is a
cumulative loss of your learner minus
the cumulative loss of the best Learner
in hindsight
so this is very similar to what group
two was proposing where you can see how
well your learner is doing at each task
as the task comes
and then I compare it to the cumulative
loss of the best Learner in hindsight
that would have had access to all of the
tasks all at once
so mathematically you can Define it as
actually I can just get the
pen
so here we have the cumulative loss of
the learner so in that case at every
time step or at every data point or
every task team you'll be coming up with
your parameters of your model Theta team
and then we'll be summing over this will
be the cumulative
um the cumulative loss of the learner
for each one of the tests so we're
summing over all the tests or all the
data points that we see
and from that we subtract the best
cumulative loss of the our locomotive
loss of the best Learner in hindsight so
in that case you have access to all of
the tasks up front you can minimize your
parameters across all of those tasks and
then the last that you get for that is
kind of the best loss you would have
gotten so have you known about all of
these tests up front what kind of lost
you would have gotten
um this cannot be evaluated in practice
because we would always need to be be
doing that
um but it's really useful for for
analysis
and um in fact I regret that it grows
linearly in team in the number of data
points this is true
um so one question I have to you is why
that is can you give me an example of an
algorithm that produces a linear regret
or regret on Gross linearly entry
you can just unmute yourself and speak
up if you if you have an idea
why does regretto cross linearly until
this trivial can you can you think of an
algorithm that produces a linear regret
any ideas here
all right not so far so that's when we
go for a little example that might
clarify this a little bit
um so the example will be the following
we'll be trying to
um predict will be situated in an in a
basketball game when you're betting on
how many points will a NBA player for
and then your loss will be dependent on
the difference between the absolute
difference between how many points they
actually scored versus how many points
you predicted that they score
all right
so for the very first game
um you get to see this new basketball
player that just joined the NBA his name
is Michael Jordan
um but you never you've never seen him
play in the NBA so you have to kind of
predict how many points he comes for you
have to make it back
right so uh based on what you've seen so
far which is basically nothing you're
predicting that you know given that I'm
given all the NBA players in the past he
might afford something like 10 points
right he's a new rookie he seems kind of
promising let's give him 10 points
that's your prediction
and then you actually get to seat the
game afterwards right and you get to
observe how many points he actually
scored
and it turns out that he scored 30
points
right
so now let's say game number two comes
about
and now you have to make a new
prediction
and let's say that you're not a very
you're very you're a very stubborn
person and you think that you're not
really going to adjust based on the
evidence that you've seen so far and
you'll just say well I'm going to
inspect them against them for 10 points
again
that's right I'll just repeat the same
back
and then you get to observe the second
game and he actually scores 28 points
right and then the same repeats would be
number three you've seen these previous
two games but again you're quite
stubborn you want to stick to your
protection you always say that he's
gonna score 10 points he actually scores
pretty two points
right so in that case we can calculate
the regrets so let's see uh maybe okay
so let's compute the first term
that's cool okay
um so the first term
um in the case of t equal one capital t
equal one would be just equal 20.
right that's the absolute difference
between uh what you predicted it was
going to be versus what it actually was
and then
e equal one we have 20
um minus the best Learner in hindsight
so the best Learner in hindsight you
would have to predict the best kind of
single number that would be 30 and then
the difference would be zero so 20 minus
zero
the regret would be 20.
right so for t equal to
right so R for a capital D rather so
we'll be now coming over
um sending over two games
um in the the original difference was
20. now you get the others from
difference of 18 so that's 38.
okay this is the cumulative loss of your
learner 38 minus the best
um learner that you could have in
hindsight
um you could have predicted an average
of those two so that would be 29 so then
the difference would be E2 because 30
minus 20 29 is 1 and 28 Minus 29 is one
as well the absolute difference
so in that case her breath will be 36.
and then for a capital
uh T equals three we would have the
difference be what it was so far so that
was
um 38 plus now that was from 22.
um so that's 60
right and then uh the best
um learner that you that you could have
in hindsight would have been the average
um so the average I press all of these
would be
um would be 30 and in that case the uh
the loss would be four so you know this
would be 56.
so now you can see that this that the
regret here at the crew by 16 right
here it grew by 20.
and if we continue doing this exercise
here on average you would be saying 10
versus here on average you'll be saying
30 so if every new game you will be kind
of getting a larger regret the regret
will be growing by 20. so we'll be
growing linearly anything
and so you're a very this is a very
simple algorithm that doesn't really
that was trivial that we don't really
adjust based on the evidence that you
see your learner your online learner is
not really getting better with more data
and with more tasks it's just constantly
outputting the same thing and in that
case the regret is linear
now you could think of a different
algorithm where instead you look at the
the best learner with us with all the
games that you that you've seen already
so rather than for the second game
predicting 10 you would predict the
score that you had in the previous game
so you would say 30 and here for the
third game you will just take the
average of the previous two games and
this is similar to fellow Follow the
Leader algorithm where you kind of take
the best algorithm
um or the best learner given the all the
previous data and apply it to the new
data form
are there any questions
all right no questions okay cool
so there was this other measure that was
much more practical that people actually
use quite often which is positive and
negative transfer
so
um and these apply to forward of those
backward transfer so the positive
forward transfer would mean that
previous tasks cause you to do better in
future tasks
and um this is something I think the
group number four discussed
um or you want to make sure that
um you know by leveraging data and from
the old tasks you're getting better and
better tasks
and this is compared to learning future
tests from scratch
and then we have positive backward
transfer which means that the current
task cause you to do better on previous
tracks
compared to learning past us from
scratch
and then if you want to think about them
as negative transfer so you would just
need to change the positive word to
negative and if you swap better but
worse you would get the definitions of
negative transfer so this is actually
measurable and this is often what people
what people use in their papers
all right cool so this was the lifetime
learning problem statement that is um
you know a little um ambiguous sometimes
where we discuss some measures of how
people measure progress on that problem
um are there any questions at this point
right no question so let's talk about
some basic approaches to like homework
so
um there are a few very basic approaches
that we can think of for instance we can
store all the data you've seen so far
and just train on it and this is what we
call Follow the Leader algorithm this is
similar to this modification of the
sports betting game where you're looking
at the average of the of the of the
points that Michael Jordan scored in the
past games
now this will achieve very strong
performance it's actually a really good
Baseline
it's computationally quite intensive you
have to store all the data that you've
seen so far and I guess in the case of
the algorithm that we discussed before
you're going to be running some kind of
running average but overall if you want
to do this applies to more complex
problems you would need to store all of
the data
um
and um and you need to kind of keep
retraining things all the time
um something like continuous fine tuning
can help here
um so this is what I mentioned before it
could be Memory intensive it depends on
the application
um the other options that you have just
take a gradient step on the data point
that you did before
so you're observe in your data point you
can take a gradients of respect to that
data point
now this is something that you actually
know and you use it all the time and
this is called stochastic gradient
so in that case it's really
computationally cheap right you just
apply a single gradient step you can you
can do this very very easily it requires
zero memory
um but it is subject to negative
backward transfer right so as you're
applying your gradients to new data
points you're not really keeping any all
data points and you're not updating your
weights based on based on those old data
points so it's quite likely that you
will forget about them
so in fact people refer to it as
forgetting or as one of the other groups
did
um catastrophic forgetting so these are
the two terms that people often use for
for this case
um the the other the the other account
of this approach is that it can be very
slow as well
all right so let's discuss
um a very simple continual our lifelong
learning algorithm that applies some of
these Concepts to reinforcement learning
and the paper is called never stop
learning it's by Ryan Julian at all
and uh it takes a look at the data that
was collected in QT app so if you
remember we had these seven robots that
collected 580 000 crafts
and then we could evaluate how well it
does on a particular scene and here we
take the specific scene where you see
those kind of objects and uh those
objects that this algorithm 500 that he
doesn't graphs such as 86 success
okay
so now we try to see if there are any
other settings where this algorithm
doesn't work that well
so in this case we looked at transparent
bottles and it turns out that the
performance would actually can't really
solve them that much so it's it only
achieves 49 accuracy
I think that that hasn't been exposed to
many transparent objects it doesn't
really know how to how to handle them
so now what we want to do is some kind
of continual around algorithm some kind
of adaptation procedure that would allow
us to improve performance on those
bottles right and this new task that is
presented for us
so the the kind of high level diagram of
this will look like this we have the old
data that we had from the pre-training
fans so this 580 000 graphs then we have
our fine-tuning tasks in in this case
these are these transparent bounds and
then we have to think of some kind of
adaptation recipe that can also use our
old policy that will get that will
achieve better results
on this on this new data
right so this is the um the fine tuning
or the the very simple continual RL
algorithm that that we came up with
um it's very very simple so this is how
it works so we start with the
pre-training data set that in this case
actually we made it a little bit bigger
it's uh 608 thousand grounds and that's
using that data set we achieve 86
um success in this original scene
now we take that base data and we train
the
um the base Q function so we just apply
standard QT opt and that's it
now uh we'll do two things we'll first
copy the weights from this original Q
function that we just learned with QT
opt and we start this will be our our
pre-training mechanism
and then in addition to this we'll be
taking the target data and we'll be
collecting very little of it only 800
grasps or sometimes even less than that
and it will be mixing that data together
with the old data in proportions 50 50.
so we'll be getting this new mixture of
data this new batch that has a little
bit of data from our Target data but
also some base data so that we don't
forget how to do it and then we'll train
we'll fine-tune our QT opt based on that
data so it's very little data but in
terms of we can do this and then we'll
have the the Adaptive Q function that
now us fine-tuned on this new data set
and it actually turns out to achieve
very high success on the underneath
house
foreign
so here are a few evaluation scenarios
that we need to consider
so again we have the pre-train on the
pre-trained setting where we achieved 86
success
and then we come out came up with a few
different scenarios for and does this
original policy didn't work very well so
we have harsh lighting we have
transparent bubbles we have checkerboard
backing that you can see in this bin
here that makes it actually quite a bit
tricky for the policy we also modified
the gripper so it's a little bit
extended here and we also offset it by
by 10 centimeters that actually looks
really funny like a Frankenstein robot
where the group is floating a little bit
next to it
um and here you see the performance that
you get with all of these modifications
for the standard utl procedure
so now we'll apply our fine tuning and
we see that we can increase by just
using less than 800 grams we can
increase the performance with fire
sliding from 32 to 63 and transparent
balance to 66 check over back into 90
extending broker to 93 and offsetting
the grouper to 98
so you can see significant Improvement
for very small amount of data by just
doing
um simple fine-tuning with Q function
right since this is a continual around
lecture we can also apply it to a
lifelong learning setting so instead of
just fine-tuning it once we can fine
tune it many times
um so what we can do here is we can
start with our original grasping data
set
we learn our Q function and we mix it
with the new data that we see in the in
the environment that we want to fine
tune to and then we can take that Q
function if we just train here that
increase the performance and then use
that Q function to initialize then take
the take the original data mix it with
the with the new scenario that we have
in mind and kind of keep doing this over
and over
now it turns out that we achieve fairly
High results for this as well so the
performance keeps growing so
um for the original harsh lighting we
have 32 percent that increases to 63 and
then even though we copied this Q
function as opposed to the original key
function that we had before it turns out
that this Q function is good enough to
then be fine-tuned to these transparent
Bubbles and Achieve
um High Improvement as well in this kind
of procedure can repeat
right one question you might have is
what about negative transfer so have we
ever tried in taking that Q function for
instance and evaluating it in this
scenario
and um we haven't tried that
um I would I would assume that it would
actually go down significantly
um we might be able to offset this by
mixing some data from the previous
experiences as well and figuring out
kind of the right way to to do this to
balance that data
um but yeah that we haven't evaluated
this newspaper and this is one of the
one of the examples of the different
lifelong learning papers care about
different things and evaluate them
different things
all right so this is a very simple
algorithm so one question you might have
is well can we do can we do better than
this
and this is um
about the last one yeah
I don't I don't really understand it's
it's not my expectation that you would
see the Improvement
um as you step to the right like
um if if that makes sense so so are you
somehow leveraging like in the offset
gripper are you somehow leveraging some
improvements that you've made just by
like diversifying your data set through
checkerboard backing and extended
gripper
um and and like if for example you just
initialized or or is it like did you
just put them in that order and if you
initialize the offset gripper with the
original purple uh model that you have
here
um yeah if you mix the order around do
you see that same
that's a great question so you're
referring to the fact that these numbers
here at the bottom keep getting higher
right yeah as opposed to like these
numbers you know the improvement from
here to here it seems like these are
improving as well
um yeah I think this is not something
that we intended
um probably a few minutes the order the
order of these numbers will also change
um so there isn't really anything I
think other than you know a slightly
differently pre-trained queue function
that you're getting at each step that
would guarantee something like this this
kind of trend where the key function
gets better and better if you look at
the way we kind of uh the order in which
we did this we did these scenarios this
is actually very similar to the order
that you've seen in the previous slide
uh as to like how good of a performance
they achieve at the end
um so we just ended up kind of sorting
them based on performance and then doing
the continual experiment this way
because it will probably look very
different the different way
okay
are there any other questions
all right cool
so I can we do better than the basics
and the case study that we'll have is
we'll look at negative transfer negative
backward transfer
um this is something that we haven't
really evaluated in the previous work
but this is something that they are
scared about in this work
um and we'll see whether we can modify
the vanilla stochastic gradient descent
to avoid negative backward transfer
and so this is the paper from Locust
passenger called gradient episodic
memory for continual learning
and the idea is the following
uh we'll store small amount of data per
task in memory
and then when making updates for for the
new tasks we'll ensure that they don't
unlearn previous tasks so this is I
think that overall makes sense the
question is how do you actually do this
how do you implement that so how can we
accomplish the number two
so first we'll be learning this
predictor that takes
um has been as into the current data
point as well as the task that it's
that's currently
um that this data point comes from
and then we're trying to find these
parameters Theta that will give us the
our prediction YT
now in addition to this we'll also keep
a memory
for other tasks that we've seen in the
past so for any K task we'll also keep
the memory that has a little bit of data
from the class
so now for the different tasks or for
every data point
we'll minimize the loss as we usually do
with the with the new with the new data
point
but then in addition to this we'll have
this constraint that says that
um the last of our new param of our new
function with the with our memory data
should be less or equal to to the loss
that we had previously in the previous
iteration on the on the previous data
and this is for the memory that was
collected for all the tasks that we that
we've seen before
right so we have this memory of 2015 so
far and we'll be evaluating the loss on
that memory with our current parameter
that we with our current um
um you can run it
um and while comparing this to the loss
that we uh that we had in the previous
iteration
and so you basically don't want to get
any words on the previous test that
we've seen
so
yeah in that case basically lost in the
on the previous task it shouldn't get
worse
um now this is what the authors do they
assume local linear writing and then
they can actually compute this inner
product
um between the gradients and that
um on the on the current task as well as
in the previous task and if that in and
if that inner product is greater than
zero then we should be good
and then they formulated and solve it as
a quadratic program
right
so then they
um do a series of experiments to
evaluate this so the the problems that
they consider are endless permutations
where you see a different permutation of
Ms and you consider it it as digit and
you consider this as a different task
you can also rotate the M nest and the m
is digit and consider that as a
different data point and they also
evaluated on c4100 where
um you have five new classes per task so
every task is considered a new task is
considered every time when you get a
fighting process
and then they look at backward transfer
as well as the forward transfer
comparing to a few different two
different based ones
and then total memory size that they
have this 500012 examples
correct
so here are some of the results so their
method is
um
their method is here
um called Gem and first you can see the
overall accuracy the classification
accuracy is quite High compared to the
baselines and then if you look at the
backward transfer
um you don't really for for their method
at least you don't really see any
negative transfer even if when you see a
little bit of a positive transfer which
is not the case for some of the
baselines
and you see a little bit of the forward
transfer as well
and then here on the right in the spot
you kind of see the effect of
catastrophic forgetting what's happening
if you don't apply
um this additional constraint that they
introduced so here what you see in this
plot is on y-axis is the accuracy of
task number one so you can see that all
of the methods achieve actually fairly
high accuracy at the very beginning when
you train on that path
and then on the x-axis here you see how
many tests you've seen so far so you
kind of see more and more tests and then
you see whether the performance of this
original task goes down as you see more
data and more tasks
and you can see that for most of the
basements that is the case the
performance goes down versus for for
their for their case because they have a
solution constraint that kind of makes
sure that you don't really go that the
gradients you apply don't really uh
forget the original task you had
um just the performance takes constant
a similar story
um also we can see similar story for Ms
rotations and you can also see similar
story for c4100 where you see that
um a lot of the
um a lot of the Baseline approaches
actually experience some kind of uh
negative backward transfer and you can
also see it here where the performance
actually drops quite significantly
compared to um compared to the method
they introduce
so one thing to consider when looking at
pictures like this is kind of verified
to is to verify the assumptions and to
see whether the setting that the authors
were considering is actually well
reflected in the experiments so in this
case if we take a if we take a step back
and uh and you know take a look whether
it makes sense to have you know a little
bit of to have a little bit of memory
per task and so on
um you know does that make sense in
terms of in the case of eminence digits
probably with Ms digits you could store
all of the data set and all the data
that you see in its entire thing right
you don't necessarily need to have a
little bit of memory that is somewhat
constrained web size it's very easy
these days to you know to uh to keep all
of this
um to have access to the entire data set
so it's often quite tricky to kind of
come up with the right experimentation
experimental setting that then addresses
the uh or has the same assumptions that
you had at the very beginning When
developing this method so that's
something to keep in mind as well
um you can also ask a question whether
we can metal learn how to avoid negative
backward transfer and there are some
papers on this um here are the two that
I would refer you to we don't have much
time to discuss them but um yeah there
are some interesting Solutions there as
well
right and in the last eight minutes
we'll talk about how we can revisit the
problems taken from the metal arrange
perspective
correct so if we look at this online
learning formulation that we had before
there might be something that's a little
bit wrong for it and I was trying to
hint at that during our record rooms
so with the online learning setting we
have to perform a sequence of tasks
while minimizing the static regret
so what that means is that you measure
the performance as soon as you're
presented with a new task for the new
data point so basically you have to
perform
um
[Music]
okay you have to perform a task straight
away and then after you finish the task
you get to see the new tasks and your
the performance is measured immediately
you know as as soon as the success is
presented to you will be measured how
well you can you can do on that task
so it's measuring the zero shot
performance
but more realistically what we might
want to have is in a setting where we
get to learn a little bit we have a
little bit of time a little bit of a
burning period where you get to kind of
see what the task is you can adapt to it
and we want to measure how fast you can
adapt and how well you can adapt in the
task so instead of just performing
straight away we'll try to learn new
tasks as we see it
cool
so in that case we want to see that we
start with very slow learning initially
it takes us a long time to learn this
initial task
but then we this this evolves to very
rapid learning over time so over time we
want to be able to uh acquire new tasks
much faster than we did at the very
beginning
and this this setting will be referring
to Us online meta learning setting where
we efficiently want to learn a sequence
of tasks from a non-stationary
distribution and this is discussed
um in this paper by uh by Chelsea Finn
actually and um and arbinger uh
all right
so it's important to note that um the
primary the primary difference here is
in evaluation rather than in the data
stream itself so you will still get to
see observe the exact same data the
exact same tasks and so on but you'll be
evaluated only after you have a little
bit of time to adapt
so for this online mental learning
setting this is what we'll do for every
task we'll observe a little bit of a of
a training data set with DTR
and then we can use some kind of update
procedure to update our parameters to
produce the new parameters that take
into account this little data set that
we just observed to produce the new
parameters by key
and then we get to observe the data
point and then we predict based on this
this updated this updated parameters and
then we get to observed like
now you can see that this last part of
this problem is the exact same as the
standard online learning setting it's
just the first part also but different
where you get to observe the small data
set that allows you to to find a better
update procedure
and then the goal is similar to what we
had before except now we have this uh
in this function
right here
um that we are also trying to uh where
we're trying to find the best update
procedure for this
um but we can still uh find the learning
algorithms stopped in your regret
Okay cool so this is the left of the
algorithm and this is the last of the
best algorithm
so the question is can we apply metal
learning in this Lifeline learning
setting and if you recall the Follow the
Leader algorithm we would store all the
data we've seen before in China so we
can have a small modification we can add
the full modifications to this algorithm
and two so that we can include meta
learning in it as well
so what we'll do instead we'll call it a
Follow The Meta leader algorithm ftml
and then we'll store all the data we've
seen so far but then we'll meta train on
that rather than just training
and then we'll run the update procedure
on the parameters
so one question you might ask us okay we
can we can do this but what kind of meta
algorithms should we use right do you
learn about different kinds of Meta Meta
learning algorithms Black Box algorithms
optimization-based algorithms and so on
so assuming that our distributions of
task is non-stationary and we might need
to
um
extrapolate
um if you recall
um one of the previous lectures by by
Chelsea on on different types of metal
learning algorithms it turns out that
optimization based algorithms such as
mammal can generalize a little bit
better outside of the training
distribution as opposed to blackbox
application algorithms so we'll use memo
and I'll try to see whether we can
implement this Follow The Meta leader
algorithms
right so the experiments are as
following we'll have the colors rotated
and scaled endless digits
we'll also have a 3D post prediction
problem where you get to see
um this image
um that is featured on the right and you
have to be able to tell what's the post
of the object in the image with respect
to this red dot that you see
and then we'll also have the C for 100
specification or new task is considered
every time you see a new class
right so the comparisons will have is
you can train them everything so train
on all the data that you've seen so far
well also compared to follow the leader
when we train on all the data all the
data that you've seen so far and then
we'll fine-tune based on the current
tasks
you can also do everything from scratch
so every time you see a new task you
train from scratch
and then we'll also compare to
um our algorithm
so first we can look at the learning
efficiency so in that case I think that
shows how much data it takes to achieve
a certain performance
so in this case you can see that so on
the y-axis it's it shows uh how much
data there there was
and to achieve a certain performance I
forget exactly what the performance was
but it was the same threshold for all of
the baselines and on the Y on the x-axis
you can see how many tasks you see so
initially you start with tasks where
you've seen 20 tests and you see task
number 122 23 24.5 and so on
so now you can see that uh ftml
algorithm follow the metador is able to
to be get more efficient over time
eventually basically going to the regime
where it can just learn a new task with
a just few shots in in a future learning
regime where you can just see a few
examples of a new task and it's going to
acquire this task very easily
and you can see the same for rainbow Ms
as well as for post-production
in addition you can also look at the
learning proficiency so the error that
that you see and here on the y-axis you
have the error but on the x-axis you
still have the task number and you can
see that also it's getting better and
better you can see more passes
so metal learns on it and gets better
and better when it gets it can train on
these tasks faster and Achieve higher
proficiency
so Follow The Meta leader you can learn
each new task faster and to have greater
proficiency
and to the point where it starts to
approach future learning routine
right so a few takeaways
we learn about many flame floor flavors
of lifelong learning and they're all
under the same thing we run through the
exercise showing you know how are the
how you can come up with slightly
different problem formulations how you
can evaluate these algorithms
differently and that's actually what you
see in the literature as well and there
even though this is a very
um diverse set of works and sometimes
they're not very comparable they could
still appear under the name of Lifeline
learning
and probably defining the the problem
statement itself is often the the
hardest part when working on these
algorithms
you can also view meta learning as a as
a slice of the lifelong learning problem
and you can apply it to
um to lifelong learning problems as well
and lastly it's a very open area of
research so a lot of the things that we
that we discussed today are very recent
works and there's a lot of people
working on these kind of problems and
reformulating them in different ways and
trying to apply some of the techniques
from other fields to see how we can how
we can apply this but as of now we don't
really have many lifelong Learning
Systems out there that are well
understood and perform very well
right
um with that these are the reminders
that we we have remember that on
Wednesday we'll also meet our Zoom we'll
have addition we'll have some
researchers talking about uh their
recent work about Frontiers in
multitasking meta learning so it should
be very interesting I encourage you to
come and ask some questions